[Music]
my you may be cleaning your makeup
brushes but did you know you also should
be cleaning your makeup I'm a board
certified dermatologist and here's how I
clean my makeup to keep my skin healthy
at least once a month you want to take
your lipstick you want to twist it then
you want to just scrape off the top
layer there then turn it over and
submerge the rest into either rubing
alcohol or vodka for 30 seconds take it
out let it air dry talk about lip
pencils eyeliner pencils brow pencils
you want to take one of those pencil
sharpeners give it one twist before each
use and you're good when it comes to
powders like eyeshadow palettes or
bronzers or blushes my go-to is 70%
isopropyl alcohol I lightly missed it
and then I let it air dry 70% is
actually better than 99% because the 99%
evaporates too quickly and doesn't kill
all the germs